hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
[Applause]
March 27 2023.
3 what do you say there how are you oh
it's March 27th oh freckles little break
here ends on March 31st a glorious
unprecedented
for the first time in 31 years
he takes three months off from the road
did a bunch of other [__] but took three
months off
you know no pandemic needed
oh freckles was [__] wheezing like an
old lady Oh Billy babushka
as they call me in Poland
when I bring my [__] jokes throat Billy
bobushka playing live
at the former Brezhnev
Memorial Arena
that they then changed right when that
[__] walrus mustachioed guy said hey
you gotta pay
it the [__] out of here right is now
what happened is that the Eastern pluck
remember on the cover of Time Magazine
whatever that guy's name was a hero
right a man with helmet hair and a big
mustache just said you know we've had
enough of this [__]
all right we've had enough of the jokes
we got a great Coastline we have great
beachfront property
it's time you guys with your [__] cars
pack up your nuclear weapons get the
[__] out of here isn't that how it went
down I don't know I was too young to
remember too young to understand
is what I should say but I only got four
days left of my vacation what do you
think I'm gonna do huh come on I'm in
Hollywood you know I'm gonna whine about
it
maybe I'll make myself a hero
you know this this vacation was for all
of you people out there in the flyover
states
you know just reminding you
to try to take care of yourselves and
take three months off
takes three months off from talking into
a microphone
see I understand I'm just like you you
people out there in the real world all
you civilians with your hard hats
ducking at the last second is a [__]
steel beam almost takes your [__]
head off I can totally relate leaning on
a plastic mic stand
I gotta take three months off hmm it's
not so much physical with my job it's
the mental aspects of it
no I'm gonna let I'm enjoy my last four
days I'm gonna drink coffee like a
[__] fiend because then I gotta take
10 days off from it
um I got all the cigars out of my house
those Cubans that somebody got me I want
to say thank you so much for them but
they once again they were not real they
weren't real none of them are real
nobody gets the real [__] you know
gets the real cigars the guys that bring
the corporations the wars that they need
to keep this country afloat those are
the guys that get the real Cubans you
think some [__] joke and [__] jackass
like me is gonna get a real Cuban cigar
maybe if I'm in Jaffa outside of Tel
Aviv and I come stumbling in
those are the last two real Cubans I got
I've had about 40 people glad I got a
cube and it's a Monte Crisco and I like
the thing I'm like this isn't real
it's not real man
it ain't real man
it ain't real unless when you light it
you spontaneously say oh my God
and the last time that's happened
was when I was in Jaffa with the great
Joe bartnick
all right
the mustachioed [__] from
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
we both just sat there smiling as we
smoked and watching all these beautiful
women
Israeli and Palestinians
you know
it was so wonderful to come there
as an outsider and just look at all
those beautiful women in just the great
weather and the Mediterranean Sea
you know and just be like what in the
[__] how did we [__] this up
oh that's right we're human beings
wouldn't it be fantastic
can you imagine that oh my God am I
going John Lennon here imagine all the
beach front
available for everyone the math doesn't
work out only a few can enjoy it
or what's the [__] point
how can you feel better than everyone
if they can all afford to live in your
neighborhood
I want to be in one of them there uh
gated community so I can feel special
see what happens where you live is you
just drive down the road buddy not me
I have to stop at a little guard house
and they gotta look me in the eye and I
gotta sit there
trying to hold my eyes open after 12
paps blue ribbons
so they can recognize my drunk face and
realize he is in fact
one of the special ones that gets to
pass through this gate I like I like
doing that
um
you'll be weird is to be an ex-president
right and just walking around you're not
doing [__] and you got these [__]
idiots standing around you still
protecting you
just want to be like guys it's over
it'd be like a former quarterback and
you're walking out to brunch and it'd be
like five three hundred pound guys
standing in front of you just in case
somebody goes for the last piece of
bacon it's like guys it's over
the game's over I'm retired
I love how they act like former
presidents are still in danger
I mean where are they you don't even see
them what was the last time he just
walked down the street and saw a former
president
you know walking up the street he's got
a you know
he's got some Ziploc bag in his mouth
because he's trying to zipper up his
[__] ex-president windbreaker
he's got a couple of cigars in there you
know they're real right
oh man that's I guess that's when you
know you're not president anymore
is when you catch the Secret Service
yawning
and somebody gives you a Cuban and it's
not real
I quit smoking but I still have my uh my
uh after pneumonia cough
I [__] up my back
uh Jesus Christ is it weird that I
watched a a YouTube video of a Jaguar
attacking an otter in the otter fought
him off it [__] annoyed me because
one time I watched an otter eat a turtle
and ever since then I've been like [__]
those things
but it's kind of funny when they fight
they make this weird noise almost like
you know like a Tesla and when a Tesla
backs up you know it makes that
does that like a [__]
like a big hound dog begging for some
food
[Music]
sorry accidentally hit stop while I was
imitating a Tesla backing up um
yeah honors do the same thing they make
the same
except they got like a raspy sound in
their voice almost like a Tesla like
post uh pneumonia they go like I I I I
kind of grew on that and the [__]
Jaguar
was like
hung in there
but you got to give it up to those
otters man those [__] things they
don't they don't mess around the Jaguar
I had to be thinking like dude
how am I not killing this thing
right
I mean Jaguars literally they kill like
up to like medium-sized alligators and
they go in the water
they don't catch them sunbathing like
the dirty reptiles they are oh
I'll tell you right now if there was if
there was a a hate group
on reptiles I would join it
I don't like hate groups with people no
I wouldn't I like animals but like
reptiles man
Jesus Christ
there's a reason why they call people
cold-blooded
you know referring
to like reptiles they just they just
don't give a [__] man
they don't care about suffering they did
they kill everything just just so damn
slow
anyway
there's no emotion behind it it's just
killing machines but anyway the Jaguars
got to be thinking like I literally beat
these [__] things in the water
you know he goes into what the hostile
environment goes into the alligators
dude I swear to [__] God this [__]
what am I doing here
I can't even do a podcast without
accidentally shutting the [__] thing
off
ah
anyway whatever the [__] riff was
that he went into the alligators hostile
[__]
environment right that's what I was
trying to talk about that's what I was
trying to say you know goes in there and
makes all the little alligators cry and
go home with their alligator pennants
going Daddy
why did the Jaguar do that
the dad alligator's got to put his
stupid [__] reptile head down and
just yeah
I don't know son
I don't know maybe because it's a better
Predator than we are
you know and those alligators got to
take that [__] loss
so then you got to think
the Jaguar goes into March Madness as a
number one seat and then all of a sudden
right
comes up against an otter
the Miami Hurricanes like that this is
they're not a [__] football school
these things can't fight off a jaguar
and then all of a sudden they go Tesla
pneumonia mode wow wow wow on its
[__] back
all right like somebody out of the the
Gracie family
the fathers of jujitsu this [__]
thing got on its back and fought this
Jaguar off and the Jaguars just I mean
it was basically on its back giving up
its neck
go ahead go for it
go for it Mr I [__] kill alligators
in their own environment
foreign
you know if I ran like a Louis Vuitton I
would have a pet [__] Jaguar
and I bring and I just have it killing
alligators Go Get It Go Get It
you have them just save the skin for me
I don't understand why
alligator shoes and all of that [__] is
so goddamn expensive
you ever been to Florida they're
everywhere like alligators I swear to
God they're like the avocados of [__]
animals why are we acting like they're
rare they're all over the [__] place
you know
this [__] people on my street have
avocado trees in their yard
I could I could plant when the thing
would live out here and then I go to get
a burrito yeah can I get some uh can I
get some uh guac oh avocados extra
like significantly extra
like that's the gold bar
of um of [__] you can put on a burrito
or on a taco or some [__] it doesn't
make any sense
well actually Bill what it is is because
the amount of water that it requires
well maybe if you build something to
catch all that water coming out of the
LA River
maybe avocado wouldn't be extra okay and
then Mr and Mrs Joe six pack
you know who eat apple pie and say
racist things could actually get a
[__]
a burrito with guacamole on it
that didn't break the bank
you know
all right sorry anyways uh anyways
I am uh
that's my deal I'm going to enjoy this
week I went I flew this weekend
I had a great time man I uh
the hell did I go I just I just flew
around the basin the Allied Basin had a
good time you know it's windy I knew it
was going to be windy on a count as I
went to wendy.com
and uh it was also you know I could this
guy was all clear
the wind was whipping around and uh you
know what's funny was
I um
we were taken off in the opposite
direction the usual direction that we
take off and then uh
I'm sitting there and I'm running the
helicopter up in this like [__] 30
people standing there staring at me
because they were giving rides in
Cessnas
[__] filming it and [__] you're like
oh God please don't let me [__] this up
so um
I did what you always do you just
[__] ignore them you stare at the
Horizon and you do slow inputs and right
as it gets light on the skin you make a
little adjustment you know so at the
last second right when you lift off you
[__] straight up and down and you
lift up like a champ you don't go left
you know go right you just [__] go
straight up
eased it out
I was in between two helicopters right I
[__] East it out no no there's
nothing behind me which is always nice
took off in the opposite direction
towards uh Bakersfield
and I got up there and everything was
going fine and then I kind of got into
the mountains a little bit got a little
bumpy and then you gotta be is this
because this is a Venturi or is because
I am sort of at Mountain level and I'm
catching that coming off the hill you
know
I made all my adjustments everything was
fine
I checked my wins and everything I was
all right 20 knots
I've flown in that before this is fine I
felt like a little grizzled vet I can
handle this what right and then I was I
was all right
it was fun
and uh
Flew Over the Rose Bowl came in the back
way which is nice
right along the golf course and all that
type of [__] over Dodger Stadium right
out over Hollywood I did that I did like
the little touristy
little touristy Loop there [__]
what's her face the vice president
whatever her name is
uh
um
God I really don't fall apart what the
[__] is her name
some reason I was thinking Gwyneth
Paltrow I know that's not it
she's an actress former actress
who now just
tells everybody how to eat
oh no she has a wellness brand
I mean that's what you gotta do you know
what happens I think in this business is
you like I want to get in the movies I
want to get in the movies I want to get
in the movies I just want to get in the
movies then you get in the movies you're
like oh my God this is so much more work
than I thought it was I don't want to do
this I don't want to do this I don't
want to do this but I like my house but
I like my house but I like my house how
the [__] can I make movie money and not
have to make a movie I know
I know how to do it
I'm gonna teach Mr and Mrs America how
to lay off a Cinnabon
and [__] I don't know have a cup of
coffee with some butter fat in it
whatever the [__] then you become an
influencer
That's Where It's At This is why this is
why
I respect this young generation
this young generation of comedians
coming up man I respect all comedians
all right but what I like what they're
doing is they're figuring it out really
early
that it's like if I just make myself my
own little [__] business then I work
for myself
you know but they're Youngs and then
nobody can steal for me you know no what
you're doing is you're limiting
the amount of people that this there's
always going to be somebody in your
pockets
all right and after they go through your
pockets and you're like well all right
that sucked at least I have this left
the government grabs you by your ankles
tips you upside down
and shakes it out before they get tipped
upside down by the Federal Reserve and
then they shake them up that's how it
works there's always somebody shaking
somebody out until you get to the
Federal Reserve and once you get to the
Federal Reserve
and once you get to the Federal Reserve
then uh
I think that's it
and those people are the ultimate people
all right they don't even have a gated
community I think they they live on like
under a mountain nobody
nobody tips them upside down
they're like hey hey I do the [__]
there's got to be the last person right
there's got to be the last part at some
point you have to run out of powerful
people and then there's got to be the
last
person but then that has to be a group
[__] back it'll be all right though I
just walk around and then yeah I [__]
act like I'm raising my hand in class
like Arnold horsch back in the day and
then I work it out
hey work it out okay baby all right
um there's got to be that last group of
[__] people
the last group of people
you know with no dick in their ass
with all the money in their pockets and
then they just sit there silently
you know having quail
isn't that what [__] illuminati
people always have like some sort of
weird bird that nobody really eats
wherever you eat it every once in a
while
[__] you talking about man I eat Quail
all the goddamn time
got them all over my prop attack all
right when I ain't eating [__] you can
guarantee yourself I'm eating some
[__] Quail whatever whatever and eat
an albatross or a condor
some sort of endangered species
you know because you're just chasing the
high I would think at that point
of exclusivity
no one tells me what to do
no one takes my money I tell people what
to do and I take their money
I eat whatever I want
my great-great-grandfather shot and ate
the last Dodo bird
I look up to him
I have alligator skin slippers
um
God that's got to be [__] Wild
to just be living like that
the whole time it must be like amazing
to just have nobody telling you what to
do and then in your back of your head
you got to be thinking like you know I
hope all this God [__] isn't real
that's what I'm banking on that you die
and you're just dead they have to be
banking on that man
making money off of [__] Wars
oh shut up Bill just shut the [__] up
and just be a goddamn comedian what are
you talking about all of this stuff for
huh
what happened you threw out your back
you woke up a little a little more
grumpier than usual
um all right guess what started this
weekend everybody not my period you
wouldn't know that by this podcast
though Moto
GPA
what it up what it up
um congratulations to Francesco
for uh he won the first [__] uh
MotoGP race of the year which was
shaping up to be exciting at the front
of the pack until Mac Marcus
I know he bumped into somebody and then
T-boned Miguel Oliveira
it was kind of funny though when he came
out of the uh the garage there and he
was all right he was like blowing kisses
the announcers were going like yeah he's
kind of hearing it from the fans because
I guess Miguel Oliveira was from uh
Portugal or whatever he was is that what
they raised I don't know I got kids
crawling all over me and I was trying to
uh watch the race and uh Mark Marquez
broke a little bone in his finger I
don't know how Miguel Oliveira is not
hurt he basically got T-boned
he was in the turn leaning down
Marquez
clip this other guy and then I don't
then he just [__] went straight into
the guy's back
and I was like oh my God he probably
I was watching the race with Dean Del
Rey because we're going to go to the
race number three
in uh Austin Texas
we're all damn goddamn liberals is that
um
in the city they're liberal when you get
outside then you get into the rich
liberals which are always fun people
Rich Liberals are the fun are very fun
people to be around
they still think they're good people
right and then they're as they're going
like can we get these homeless people
off of our sidewalks wait I thought you
were liberal
oh listen I paid a lot of money
to be in this neighborhood I still care
about the little guy I just don't want
to watch him struggling on the sidewalk
in front of my house
I want to feel safe when I go out to my
Tesla
um
all right what am I talking about here
um so I guess Mark Marquez is going to
take the next race off because he broke
a little bone in his hand
uh but it was exciting I think he was I
think he got the pull I kind of miss all
the time trials but it's nice to see him
riding aggressive that's what he used to
do he used to just ride up on people
push him off the track they would wipe
out and then he would turn around do the
wave oh sorry about that
you know
and then after the race he'd be like uh
I don't know what happened there uh I
tried to go uh to the inside and uh
I'm sorry
uh but you know that is racing and uh
[__] him
I love Mark Marcus by the way and I'm
not making fun of his English the man
can speak more than one language so he
is better than me but it is fun to
listen to that
uh I am sorry to uh Miguel Oliveira
um it was uh all of my fault and uh
um sorry to his fans
um
and uh
uh that's it it was my fault
that's how I speak French
except I I go
um
je m'appelle Guillaume uh
um oh [__] uh
shows uh
uh
uh do love you know everybody does that
when they when they're learning another
language right thanks Bill thanks the
guy's fully fluent and you're [__]
comparing yourself to him what is wrong
with you this week
so anyway race number two is in
Argentina Mark Marquez will not be there
all right
we'll uh
it kind of sucks that he does if the
same guy wins again francese go back if
he wins again
I know it's just great because I missed
all of last season because I was so
goddamn busy but um
it was Chris great to hear those names
again
okay the best best part of the race was
watching uh Johan zarco pass Alex
Marquez and Brad
Jack thrillermilla
um he's good for a couple wins a year
oh he's like that's the closest thing
to an American
that we have at the MotoGP
uh level that's why I've been watching
Joe Robertson uh Moto gp2 which you
can't let you can't see
the gp2 race in [__] um
on their website I can't find it I'm
trying to figure out how you can watch
the uh gp3 and gp2 race I don't know
whatever I'll get to see him race in
Austin Texas really looking forward to
that there's actually one other American
at the uh Moto gp2 uh level and I'm
hoping that uh
I want to see an American at the top
level
you know but the closest thing I got is
I believe he's English
I have no idea anyway
I'm looking forward to it so the Miami
Hurricanes are in the final four as is
Yukon I think everybody's bracket kind
of blew up
with uh who had the Miami Hurricanes who
had Princeton going as far as they did
I mean who didn't watch a game and still
like [__] filled out a bracket and
had the nerve to be upset like me
as you just picked you know long time
storied schools like Kansas and
University of Indiana
that's what I did
um
anyway so as I mentioned I'm going on
the road this week my cigars are gone
I now will smoke a cigar
uh
if it's like an event
all right but I'm just gonna be sitting
here
out on my back porch smoking a cigar
talking to myself
you know late at night and my wife what
are you coming to bed
I don't know
all right I'm coming well forget it then
don't come up
all right let me do a little bit of uh
I feel like somebody punched me in my
kidney all right let's do some reads
here man oh look who it is
luck be a lady tonight it's fume
everybody f u m e be smart don't start
kick the habit put it out before it puts
you out all phrases we've heard a
hundred times yet we still continue to
have bad habits personal struggle any
bad habit that's hard to kick the story
all right boozing how about boozing
um what have I tried to to stop uh
yelling
um sugar
uh alcohol I haven't drank in uh close
to four and a half years
and uh I'll never go back to that [__] I
don't think so
and if I do
you know
that happens
uh people say I'll never date a psycho
again and next thing you know you meet
that new girlfriend you're like this is
the same person with smaller tits
you're literally dating the same person
again you know she Parts her hair on a
different side of the head but it's the
same [__] person
yeah we've all we've all struggled
anyway our sponsor fume oh God they got
the umlot over it is it from whom is on
a mission to accelerate Humanity's
breakup from the bad habits that consume
far too many of us from is a natural
diffuse oh my God I gotta use this
diffusive device that uses plants and
Behavioral Science to help you trade out
your negative habit for a positive one
foom is not a vape it's a non-electronic
device designed to transform your
negative habits instead of PODS filled
with potentially harmful chemicals like
a vape fume uses chorus c-o-r-e-s
infused with plants like peppermint and
cinnamon for delicious natural flavors
fumes new version 2 model is a Snappy
tactile
wait with an adjustable airflow dial and
a magnetic end cap your fingers will
always have something to do
so what if your fingers are busy you
won't be [__]
[__] cooking up some heroin I didn't
expect much out of foom when I got it
but the minty sensation is really
powerful and really hits the back of the
throat I haven't used this [__] people
the easiest way to stop a bad habit is
to switch to a positive one and fum foom
is designed perfectly to just do that
it's foam's goal to make switching easy
and even enjoyable okay so you're
replacing
a bad habit with this this device they
have thousands of five star review from
people just like you who've successfully
switched when other Solutions just
didn't work well listen if you're trying
to kick a bad habit hey give this [__] a
try had to try fum
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use the code bird to
save 10 off when you get the journey
back today the journey pack comes with
three unique flavors and the new version
to fum
F Dash U Dash
oh try Dash F Dash U Dash m.com
no there is no dash in it
I think it's tryfum.com
and use code bird to save an additional
10 off on your order today hey you want
to quit a bad habit starts
sorry Simply Safe For the record people
I do do these podcasts in the morning
that's why I sound like this
and I smoke cigars for 10 years and I
had pneumonia there's my excuses all
right
Simply Safe everybody you know who's
playing to do who's planning to do some
spring cleaning this year dust those
hard to reach places
uh uh clean out that closet you know the
one here's my advice clean your house
and then protect every inch of it with
Simply Safe home security I recommend it
to everyone SimpliSafe is designed with
Cutting Edge technology and backed by 24
7 Professional monitoring in an
emergency agents use fast protect
technology
only from SimpliSafe to capture critical
evidence and verify the threat is real
he's got it
so you can get priority police dispatch
24 7 Professional monitoring Services
cost just under a dollar a day less than
half the price of traditional home
security system you can lock and unlock
your doors access your cameras and arm
and disarm your system from anywhere
CNET named Simply Safe editor's choice
for 2023. uh customize the perfect
system for your home in just a few
minutes at simplysafe.com
I like how I went up there in just a few
minutes didn't that make it sound like
it was going to be easy go today go
today and claim a free indoor security
camera plus 20 off your order with
interactive monitoring that's
simplysafe.com
this no safe like SimpliSafe
all right I got some new dates everybody
I got some new dates
um
on the docket here June 23rd Bridgeport
Connecticut at the total mortgage Arena
that has got to be the worst name for a
[__] Arena since jobbing.com total
mortgage
[__] total mortgage dude uh June 7th
and 8th Atlantic City New Jersey at the
Hard Rock Live
at the e-test arena
I love Atlantic City uh pre-sale is
Wednesday March 29th 10 a.m local time
uh artist code is burp b-u-r-r General
on sale Friday March 31st 10 a.m local
time I will tell you this people I don't
think I've been this excited to go out
on the road in a long time I got a bunch
of new stupid [__] I am going I'm not
I'm telling you I'm gonna [__] murder
when I'm out there I can feel it I got
my whole new hour I know the direction
that I want to uh bring it in I got the
name of my special I'm [__] I'm ready
to go I am locked I am not loaded I
gotta go on the road and do the work now
now I gotta Build It Up
I gotta Build It Up
um
all right because I'm old school I'm old
school I'm about I'm about the hour
and a half to hour and 15 minutes of
material I'm still doing that I'm still
putting out albums
during an era when it's all about the
single
right
um I was talking about that earlier
though like the the level of marketing
skills by today's Young comedians is
[__] astounding the way that they
figure it out and all of that and then
all of these [__] [__] storms
that they can now avoid and go directly
to their fans and build an audience
is uh I gotta be honest with you it's
pretty goddamn exciting
um it's fun to watch
um CFL football stadiums oh here we go
I was talking about this hey Billy our
balls are bigger
uh a CFL slogan from the 90s
oh that's great I I loved your bit about
CFL State stadiums yeah I was making fun
of how they look like old NFL stadiums
from the 1960s as a Canadian we love
making fun of ourselves sorry about that
um are you making fun that you apologize
or
you know I don't know what you're saying
there I I don't I don't I don't try to
understand Canadians you all have that
weird look on your face
it's like are they going to shake my
hand or bury a hatchet into the back of
my head you cannot read a Canadian
um and they all wear the same winter
coat like those [__] kids on South
Park
um you the one with the little [__]
bear or something holding a flag that's
like big status
that you can afford the really expensive
goose down jacket anyway you definitely
need to attend some CFL games while
you're in Canada you will be surprised
to see how modern some of the stadiums
in the CFL actually are Saskatchewan
probably has the best stadium in the CFL
I don't want to go to those I want to go
to a [__] old school one that like
Warren Moon played in or Doug Flutie
um not to mention the most passionate
fans in the league Winnipeg stadium
looks like a smaller version of lumen
field in Seattle oh
no
Tim Hortons field in Hamilton how Canada
how Canada is that to name your oh how
Canadian is that how Canada is that how
Canadian is that to name your Stadium
after Tim Hortons I think it's awesome
is smaller is smaller stadium with great
sight lines and atmosphere
all right oh ham Hammer Hamilton Hammer
town is that is it is that it south of
Toronto
where a lot of people don't know this
that's uh I played that theater that's
where Bill Cosby did one of the greatest
stand-up specials of all time despite
his offstage behavior he did uh Bill
Cosby himself
there I believe in my hometown of
Vancouver British Columbia uh BC Place
Stadium was completely renovated in 2011
and features a retractable roof oh
that [__] roof works one time and
then it's just busted
like remember uh Montreal the Expos when
they had Olympic stadium and we get a
little crane and it's going to take the
top off like a little yarmulk they did
that like once and they're like all
right [__] that [__] uh 55 000 seats in
one of the best video screens in North
America
yeah because that's what I want to do
when I [__] go to a game is watch a
TV screen dude none of this [__] is cool
to me I wanted it [__]
old school [__] where people are
just there to watch the goddamn game and
and curse at the field and take out
their frustrations of their own personal
life on the coach that's my idea of
watching a sporting event personally
all right anyway
BC Place will be one of the hosts of the
2026 FIFA World Cup whatever the [__]
that is is that the soccer
I know what that is I'm just [__]
with you CFL football is very exciting
version of the game okay they only get
three Downs
so it's a pass first league on a much
bigger field with unlimited pre-snap
backfield motion I do like that
uh CFL I like I like how like you're
watching and right before they snap the
ball the receiver comes running by the
screen like some fan ran on the field
we're going straight good
um CFL rules also make it really hard to
run out the clock which makes for a lot
of exciting finishes
uh uh hope you make it to a game of
Saskatchewan Winnipeg Hamilton you will
have a great time and Come Away With A
New Perspective about the CFL
um I've always liked the CFL I don't
have a problem with it it's football I
love your podcast keep making fun of us
Canadians and go [__] yourself all right
you got it
all right money money money to build
uh dear Billy boy on your podcast today
you read to you read a listener email
you read a listener's email that's what
it just said
um that mentioned the expensive new
Federal Reserve building
oh is it a new building I thought they
were renovating it
um the email seemed to be complaining
that their tax dollars went toward the
construction of this building
um the Federal Reserve does not receive
taxpayer funding holy [__] is this a guy
from the Federal Reserve clapping back
uh instead it gets most of its money by
collecting interest off of government
securities it owns despite its name the
Federal Reserve is not actually part of
the federal government yes everybody
knows this at this point it's as Federal
as Federal Express we all know this
maybe this is a good reminder to your
listeners and all of us to do a little
bit of thinking before wasting our time
getting pissed off about [__] that isn't
even real
um okay but doesn't it bother you that
our government doesn't print our money
and that a private Corporation does and
charges us interest and has helped
bankrupt this [__] country
is that what you're trying to say
oh my God
Jesus Christ this guy was just like
you know what I'm going to call that
email defending Hitler's mustache
his mustache wasn't that bad Charlie
Chaplin also had a mustache like that as
did Michael Jordan as Charles Barkley
pointed out in one of those underwear
commercials in the entire time you avoid
that he he orchestrated the Holocaust
all right
yeah I think I just coined a new phrase
defending Hitler's mustache
that is when you ignore the 800 pound
[__] uh Nazi in the room
and just talk about his grooming
um anyway you should buy this oh my God
what can this be a new [__]
segment it's bringatrailer.com listing
1969 Ford F-250 what
ah
oh my God
why did you do that to me
oh my god oh it's sold oh thank God it's
sold it sold for 70 grand 69 000 dollars
oh my God
oh my God is that [__] gorgeous
Jesus Christ but what are you looking at
I'm looking at a 1969
Ford blue F-250 four-wheel drive
I don't know if they were called High
boys yet
um it's got uh the white Grill
same front end as my 68 they changed
them in 70.
oh it's got the big camper [__] uh
mirrors on the side does not have the
Dual what is the gas tank on this
[__] thing
oh maybe it's behind the license plate
maybe they moved around it's got the
eight foot bed oh let's read about this
this truck is said to have left the
factory equipped with a platform bed and
a replacement cab and style side bed
we're sourced from a two-wheel drive
pickup truck of the same model year okay
so this thing's been [__] with the
front fenders were I don't care the
front fenders were also replaced holes
were patched and dents were repaired
before repaint in blue this thing still
got 70 grand the front brush guard Grill
and bumpers were refinished in white
and additional details include tow
mirrors and Montana themed rear mud
flaps
oh there's the gas cap they just painted
it blue
uh okay okay
um
the seller notes dense in the bed
in an area of touch-up paint on the
front bumper that is shown wow man this
thing's got a lot of little uh it's got
a lot of character white 16 inch steel
wheels are mounted
okay let's see what we got here
let's see what we got here we got a nice
bench seat it's unfaded that's always
cool
oh it's a four speed I like that
what's it guys I got the 390 It's gotta
have the 390 right
can't read it that's the 360 or the 390.
oh the 360 the smaller of the two
engines I'm glad I laid off this still
cool though
well it looks like they did the
underneath is all brand new oh look at
that that is nice
further work performed during the
rebuild included oh man
I [__] love a truck I wish my truck
would show up oh that's what it
originally looked like
I know what the that was an ugly ass
truck
all right
I like it you getting close
I'm kind of like a chick right now where
you feel like you did something really
nice to me and then I just [__] about
it
um
okay guys whatever you do don't show me
a mint condition 1969 Cadillac Eldorado
um
I want one of those [__] things I
don't need it nobody needs it but you do
need it you know
you know what I want one of you guys to
do I want you guys to want you guys to
buy the [__] El Dorado the year the
same year as when
um
De Niro's character gets blown up in it
when he's playing uh Ace Ross theme Sam
Ross theme Ace frosting
um I guess that thing it just so
happened there was something wrong with
the balance on the car so they had to
put a metal plate underneath the
driver's side so it would drive like a
Cadillac and it was that piece piece of
metal that saved him from getting blown
up
I mean
I bet Ace Rossi went home that night and
when his ears stopped ringing probably
did the math to try to figure out what
the odds were
that somebody tried to blow him up in a
car
that actually had a don't [__] blow
me up plate on it
I wonder what the odds are of that oh
gee Bill aren't you just [__]
inquisitive today
all right movie pick
oh before we get into this guess what I
watched I got a little about 40 minutes
left in it I watched Sean Penn
um Christopher Walken
and one of my favorite actors slash
storytellers rest in peace Chris Penn in
at close range
um
Christopher Walken is just so [__]
crazy and Sinister in that movie
performing I miss Christopher Walken
he's [__] amazing
um
and Sean Penn you know
as always is amazing everybody in the
movie I just uh I love the cars in the
movie I like the story
um I really thought I don't know why I
just like the 80s I'm kind of coming
back to it where I was just like
I never had Nostalgia for it I was just
thinking like
this is just always gonna look cheesy
like the 80s is just always gonna look
cheesy with the [__] pastel it was
the worst era ever
hands down not even close for American
cars
for just cars in general
I would say maybe like BMWs Mercedes
Jaguars were terrible All American cars
sucked
like if you if you're really looking on
the on these these these Mecum Auctions
nothing from the 80s ever comes through
and if it does it's always under a
hundred grand I would say the only thing
that ever seems to make money is like a
Buick Grand National
um and then I think maybe like foreign
cars
like occasionally maybe like a Nissan
will get it fetch a little bit of money
but nobody gives a [__]
about the Camaros and all of that as far
as like they're not like six figures I
don't know I should probably shut up
because I haven't watched enough of it
but like I just don't see stuff
you know over the years like all of a
sudden more late model cars have come
out but a lot of them are like from the
90s
[Music]
um
you know the Porsches from the 80s of
course are worth a lot of money
but everything else is just you know
I mean just think of the Chrysler
product great the Great
Dodge Chrysler Hemi all of that they're
[__] legend in the 80s the Dodge K
cars
their attempt
at like [__]
having a badass car the [__] Chrysler
Laser
all of those ones and then Chevy with
like the Fiero and the Lumina
what the Chevy Nova became
Chevy Chevette petering out
economy cars I mean it was just [__]
awful
it was awful that was a bad time to be
on The Price is Right you could win this
I know car yes it's the 1983 Chevy Nova
four-cylinder four speed
that was actually my dad had one of
those it was a [__] great shifting
car I'll tell you that
nice smooth
shifting I'll tell you what was cool
um
my boss when I worked in the warehouse
had one what the [__] was it he had a a
Toyota Supra
in red like an 84 and 85.
he let me borrow that car one weekend
when he borrowed my truck to move I lost
in that [__]
that switch although I was a fun car to
drive
um
as he put two refrigerators in a [__]
L-shaped couch in the back of my little
Ford Ranger
two-wheel drive eight foot bed
four-cylinder five-speed vinyl seats
um
anyway fire engine red
what else nothing else AM radio
I was styling
yeah so I didn't I didn't think that any
of that [__] would ever come back and uh
but now I'm watching these movies
from like the 80s
and uh and I'm looking at a lot of the
cars and everything and what's funny too
is like
it was like cars from the 60s were just
to drive around the cars in the 60s now
that it was like 20 years old or
whatever they were just starting to
become Classics and starting to be like
worth some money like I can't imagine
what you could have got some of those
muscle cars for like during the first
you know gas crisis and all of that [__]
but anyway I'm finally out of the 70s
which I feel has been done to death
and uh the 60s I like but like there's
still that leftover like
Why I oughta kind of acting you know
which makes it a little difficult to
like
people are sort of starting to catch up
with the um
I would say uh Marlon Brando's and and
that type of [__]
you know
um coming out of the the Steve McQueen
Charles Bronson classic tough guy actors
and then you actually get like uh
I don't know like Dennis Hopper and
people like that De Niro and all of them
starting to get their first work towards
the late 60s and of course you Devour
the 70s then you go into the 80s and
this you know here's some movies I would
say I'd say to Live and Die in LA if you
can [__] find it
at close range is a great one
uh
um
Sharky's Machine
it's a little uneven
but I just love that Burt Reynolds did
that movie
um
that movie Thief
with uh James Khan blowout John Travolta
these are the movies that I've been
watching so far and I've loved every
single one of them and I've actually
there's been a few cars that I saw
like I said a Chevy Monza like what the
[__] ever happened to those things or my
favorite one of all time
oh what was that car the Chevy citation
which I always bring up on this podcast
like it wasn't a [__] sedan it wasn't
a hatchback it was like it was like the
hot dog of cars where it's just Pig
[__] and [__] toe cheese and they
just shove it in a [__] sausage that
was that was it was the car version of
that
and they forgot to design a radio in it
they slapped it together so quickly so
they ended up putting the radio in
vertically and they didn't even change
the numbers you had to like turn your
head my buddy had one
it was [__] insane
it was like a uh it was like did
somebody just build this in their
backyard from spare parts they're like
nope this came from the GM factories
um
anyway
so
um all right what are we doing here I am
reading uh your movie pick for this week
guys you're sending me old vintage
trucks and movies
Jesus Christ I'm ready I'm ready to
propose here
uh movie pick I heard a clip with Bill
asking for lesser known flicks that may
give a shot in the arm for screenplay
ideas oh let me get to Chris Penn one of
the reasons why I love that guy other
than that I love his acting he's one of
the great storytellers of all time if
you can somehow watch the DVD extras of
Reservoir Dogs and him telling the story
of um that the old actor on it so you
like to tell jokes Kegler like a bunch
of school girls sitting in a ball it is
a joke for you
a bunch of guys sitting around the
bullpened what and how we got there
what do we do what should we have done
I used to know that whole thing
then they realized the whole time we
were planning this caper
we were telling jokes that was it so you
like to tell jokes Caitlin like a
punches Lawrence Tierney or something
like that Lewis Tierney whatever Chris
Penn tells this amazing story of that
guy taking like 12 buses to come over
and meet with him before they work on
the movie and bringing like luggage to
then stay at his house when Chris never
said you could stay at my house it was
just like just effortless
effortless storytelling and he just
um
what a [__] loss man
it's incredible incredible those those
you know I find a lot of great actors
because I used to watch that Inside the
Actors Studio which was always sort of
funny with that guy just drooling
um
drooling over like whatever actor you
I'll help you people realize
the prodigious wow like he was like
foaming at the mouth
um
and how great these [__] uh you know
actors were
um anyway like I I always put like um
like Chris Penn as far as like I always
liked actors like that are like Tom
seismo just recently passed away rest
his soul where like I always just felt
like they they had like this thing where
they they could they were just so
[__] grounded
and whatever they were doing
um
I don't know Tom Sizemore I literally
felt like that guy could just any line
you gave him if he just said it you
believed it
um another great loss anyways um here's
a movie pick I heard a clip with Bill
asking for lesser known flicks
that may give a shot in the arm for
screenplay ideas
um night and the city a 1979 remake of
the 1950 Noir Classic
well now I gotta watch both of those
great cast Robert De Niro Allen King
Jack Ward and Alan King did two movies
with Dinero uh Jessica Lange
at the height of her hotness now wait a
second guys I can't be a part of this
okay
how come you didn't say Robert De Niro
at the height of his handsomeness
how come you didn't say Alan King at at
the height of his whatever the [__] he
was doing
um
Jessica Lange I mean that that name is
hot you just know she's going to be
beautiful
um anyway also has a two scene Cameo
from Regis Philbin
not to be
uh enjoy De Niro's last line kills me
all right well there you go
I'm all over that night and not night in
the city people night and the City
1979 remake go and check that one out
all right well I'm a happy man baseball
starting March Madness is wrapping up
NHL NBA playoffs
um are starting and Moto GP
ball you F1 fans I think you guys are
three four races in
what is that
what is this mumbling [__]
oh so is that mine
oh that's my phone
who the hell was that guy
oh future
wait a second it just said March Madness
is my phone listening to me
I just literally said March Madness and
then a song by Future came on called
March Madness
all right I'm Gonna Act Like That Wasn't
creepy as hell
you know what it was I was [__]
talking about the Federal Reserve that's
what it was man you know they're worried
this podcast is gonna bring it all down
man
anyway have I been I told you guys my my
uh my my little drum calisthenics that
I've been working on all right here's
for the drummers out there
all right
left kick kick 60th notes
all right quarter note hi-hat
you play a bar of that
and then you go into right left kick
still playing 16th notes so it becomes
three against four
when you get to the One You're Gonna
land on the left hand
and then it's left kick kick right left
kick kick right left kick kick right
left kick kick right left kick kick and
then you're gonna start with the one
left kick right left kick right left
kick right left kick you'll come out
leading with the bass drum foot
and then it's kick kick right left kick
kick right left kick kick right left
kick kick right left kick
right left kick right left kick right
left kick right three against four
and then you come out
with uh kick one double kick there
then it's kick one left oh kick one
right left kick kick but kick kick there
kick kick right left kick kick right
left kick kick right left kick kick
right left kick
uh
uh you'd land on the bass drum then kick
right left kick right left kick right
left and then you come back around again
to right left kick kick I hope that made
sense you're basically just moving
around the quad
and in between those you're doing a
right left kick thing a three against
four thing that I learned from JP bouvet
off of his uh website combining [__]
here people
then you mix it all up and every once in
a while you throw in uh a grouping of
uh four
four stroke 16th with your right left
right left switches everything up and
you just keep the quarter note pulse
and you just blaze around the kit and
everybody thinks like holy [__]
what is this
it's nothing it's literally
[__]
moving the quad around
with the three against four thing going
in and out of it and then throwing in
just a [__] with people's ears
four single Strokes to turn it around
and then everybody just thinks uh
you know it's kind of like this podcast
you listen to it you think I'm saying
something and by the time you realize
that I'm not it's over and it is over
people that's the podcast for this week
one hour one minute and 38 seconds how
do you like that
all right that's it go [__] yourselves
uh have a great couple of days and I
will check in on you on Thursday